So we're going to talk very briefly about logging and analysis right now, and then we'll
get into a little more deeply when we talk about security information and event management
systems in domain 7.
But let's start with the basics.
Why do we logging and monitoring?
I like this slide.
It does a good job of summarizing why we do this.
First of all, we only want to log what is relevant.
It is absolutely possible with our systems to produce, especially modern systems, to produce
an unbelievable amount of logging data.
But we don't care about all of that.
You only want to log what is relevant.
How do you determine how to log what is relevant?
A really good way of doing this is to go back to risk management.
If you think about what are the key risks for an asset, that's a pretty good way of thinking
about how would we detect if one of those risks had occurred?
Maybe that's what we should turn logging on for.
So only log what is relevant.
And then review those logs.
Someone has to be proactively or some system has to be proactively looking at those logs.
And this is where you truly do new system.
Modern day systems can produce just, especially in a big environment.
You can have millions of events happening per second.
And there's no way that a person could actually look through that.
You need a system involved that's able to look at all this event data and be able to identify
useful information.
And you really do want to be reviewing the logs proactively.
You can just go back and look at the logs after you've had a breach, but it's better to
do it proactively.
And then the final thing, what are you actually looking for?
Well, you're looking for things like errors and anomalies.
And here's a good summary, right?
Errors, unexpected errors, are a good indication that a system might not be working properly.
Modification to a system, especially if it's unauthorized modification.
That's probably something you want to look at and breaches.
Now as I mentioned in domain seven, we'll go into seam, sim systems, and much more detail.
And we'll talk through all the steps that they go through for the aggregation generation,
correlation of logs.
We'll talk about that later on.
For now, let's just say that when it comes to where can we collect a log event data from
everywhere?
And what do we want to do?
We want to pull all that data into our log correlation system into one central system so
that we can then analyze that data, look for the proverbial needle and a stack of needles.
One of the problems we face when logging is our endpoint devices, things like our firewalls,
can produce an enormous amount of logging data.
But they typically have very limited storage on board.
And so if we have a requirement to keep a huge amount of logging data, it's often difficult
or impossible to do that on the endpoint.
So let's talk about a couple of methods of how we can limit log file sizes.
Two major methods that you need to know about, circular overwrite and clipping levels.
Now let's start with circular overwrite.
The way circular overwrite works is you set a maximum log file size or length.
And then you start writing log event data until you reach the maximum file size or the
maximum number of lines and then you circle back to the top and start overwriting.
That's circular overwrite.
And what it means is that your log file size is never ending at larger than the maximum
number of entries or the file size that you set because as soon as you reach that maximum,
you circle back to the top and start overwriting.
The other method you can use is what's known as clipping levels.
When clipping levels is this idea that we set a threshold below that threshold, don't
bother logging anything.
Above that threshold, start logging.
Here's an example.
Failed or incorrect passwords.
So when I change my password for the first month or first week anyways, I type in the
wrong password and it's a failed log event.
This happens all the time for people.
And so the vast majority of the time, if you see one failed log in attempt, it's not concerning.
So you might set a threshold and you would say, you know what, below say three failed log
in attempts in 30 seconds or not going to log anything.
So all those times that people are just fat fingering their password or forgetting their
password, you're not logging any of that.
But if you suddenly see like 50 failed log in attempts within 30 seconds, should you be
logging that?
Absolutely.
That's probably someone trying to brute force your system.
And so that's the idea of clipping levels.
You set a threshold below that threshold, don't log anything.
Love that threshold, start logging.
Here's a good question.
Which of these methods, circular overwrite or clipping levels, would be better if you
wanted to detect a breach?
And the answer is clipping levels.
And the reason is that with circular overwrite, if you want to investigate a breach, you need
the log data.
And in circular overwrite, you're erasing your log data, data, you're overwriting your
data once you get to a certain point.
Whereas with clipping levels, you're limiting the amount of data, but you're not ever
overwriting it.
So if you get a question like that, the better type of logging, of a better method of
limiting log file sizes, if you're looking for a breach, is clipping levels.
Final part about logging here that I want to mention.
And this relates to the time that we attach to a log file.
You want to have consistent timestamps.
I'm going to talk later on in the SIM system about how if you want to correlate events,
line them up with each other.
You need to have consistent timestamps.
Has to be the same date, you know, same year, month, day, format, same, 12 or 25 hour
clock format, whatever it is, make it consistent.
The final piece is all of the systems in your environment need to have the same system
time.
If you want to be able to trace, track, how in a tracker, how an attacker traversed your
network, got into different systems, got a foothold here and then moved there, it is
very difficult to trace and figure out exactly what someone did, an attacker did, if your
systems have different clock times, if this one's five seconds faster, that one's three
seconds slower, it becomes very difficult to trace events.
And so the way that we can make sure that all of our systems, clocks are aligned is through
the MNTP protocol, network time protocol.
And as the name implies, this protocol allows a server to synchronize its system clock.
And there are basically what you can connect with this is an atomic clock.
And through the MNTP protocol, you can synchronize your system clock with one of these world
atomic clocks through NASA or other US agencies and other agencies around the world.
And if every system in your environment is using the MNTP to synchronize the system
clock, all the servers in the environment, all the systems in the environment will have
the exact same time.